-And finally, guys,
it's Wednesday.
You know what that means.
It's time for some
Monday Motivations.
-Monday Motivations.
[ Laughter ]
-Secretly, the Kardashians
are just trying
to keep up with you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Every time you have
an appointment,
your dentist
calls his friends like,
"You'll never guess where
my hand is right now.
Yes, Jeffrey's mouth!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
When people see you in a club,
they're like,
"Whoa, how'd I get into
the VIP section?"
[ Laughter ]
You wore a winter coat
last week,
and now everyone's wearing
a winter coat.
That can't be a coincidence.
Congratulations, trendsetter.
[ Applause ]
Every time people see you,
they're like,
"Mistletoe?"
[ Laughter ]
When you go down the line
and say what you want
at Chipotle,
the workers are like,
"Right answer. Right answer."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, you're the "you"
Mariah keeps saying
that she wants for Christmas.
That's why they play it
every time
you go into the CVS!
All she wants is you!
[ Cheering ]